[Music]
Hello, how are you? Sal and Jaramillo greet you
with their brief information for today,
Wednesday, May 12. The authorities have still
not found the body of the 2-
year-old boy,
Amorín Ecos, reported
missing since last week
until this morning. The police continue
the investigation.  search although it is said that the minor
was murdered the mother's boyfriend
identified as
27-year-old chevrolet brothers was arrested after confessing that
he killed the child roads has its first
hearing today the price of gasoline
continues to rise in nevada the average for
a tank  gas is 50 cents
higher than the national average
this translates to 3 dollars and 55
cents per gallon in the county with the
overall average being 3 dollars and 57
cents and last returns las
vegas' will open in  next season in
primetime inside the free stadium
the riders will take on the baltimore
ravens on a monday night in the
first week of the season the rest of the day
the nfl schedule will be announced in
the next few hours now with your
weather forecast a sunny day is expected
with temperatures near 95
degrees for tomorrow the temperatures will
rise remember not to leave your
children or pets in the vehicle
unattended have a nice day  I am
salt and jaramillo with his brief information
for broadcast in Spanish
[Music]